bonjour à tous
dans ma vidéo consacrée
spinoza j'annonçais que j'avais pris mon
temps avant de réaliser cette vidéo
parce qu'on ne s'attaque pas un monument
de la philosophie tels que spinoza sans
s'y être préparé
aujourd'hui je publie une vidéo sur
hegel et si la précaution était valable
pour spinoza elle devient indispensable
s'agissant de hegel faire une vidéo sur
un penseur de ce calibre c'est prendre
un énorme risque
c'est partir du principe qu'on n'aura
pas le temps de tout dire et que dire le
tout de la philosophie de hegel
c'est aussi compliqué que dire le tout
tout court car en l'occurrence la
philosophie de hegel se veut elle aussi
une philosophie de la totalité alors au
lieu de passer par des chemins détournés
au lieu d'emprunter un langage trop
abstrait j'ai fait le choix
méthodologiques de vous introduire à la
pensée de hegel à travers ce que
j'estime être son son concept
fondamental et le concept fondamental à
mon sens de la philosophie hégélienne
c'est le concept de dialectique
alors quand je définis la dialectique
comme un concept
je fais déjà une première approximation
peut-être même une première erreur mais
ce n'est pas grave
parce que vous le verrez avec eagle
l'erreur fait partie de la connaissance
pourquoi est-ce que la dialectique n'est
pas à proprement parler un concept parce
qu'un concept
ça renvoie à une idée générale ça
renvoie à une abstraction
par exemple le concept de liberté
le concept de bonheur le concept de
droit alors que la dialectique
ça renvoie non pas à une idée mais
plutôt un mode de fonctionnement un
processus dynamique la dialectique ça
désigne la manière dont le réel se
comporte alors ça peut paraître étonnant
de parler du comportement du réel comme
si le réel et est doté d'un tension
comme s'il était doté d'une personnalité
est ce que hegel personnifie le réel non
mais il identifie dans le réel
un principe qui est le principe
rationnelle et dont la dialectique
constitue la mise en oeuvre dans le
monde matériel
on va évidemment revenir sur tout ça
mais avant je dois faire une parenthèse
en évoquant brièvement la dialectique
dans la grèce antique chez socrate la
dialectique désigne un mode de
raisonnement basé sur le principe de la
réfutation la dialectique
c'est une méthode qui permet de
soumettre l'interlocuteur à une série de
contradictions
une série de réfutation et qui permet au
terme du processus de réfutation de
parvenir à une vérité de parvenir à une
connaissance solide qui aura triomphé de
l'épreuve de la contradiction et c'est
quelque chose qu'on utilise encore
aujourd'hui notamment dans la méthode
scientifique à savoir contestent des
hypothèses et on écarte toutes les
hypothèses qui se révèle fausse
qui se révèle invalides et par là même
on conserve ce qui aura su résister à
l'épreuve de la contradiction
on dira donc que la dialectique
c'est une méthode qui consiste à
parvenir aux vrais par éliminations
successives du faux si je devais
simplifié à outrance je dirais que ça
rejoint le raisonnement par élimination
vous savez dans ce fameux jeu télévisé
on vous pose une question et vous avez
quatre possibilités de réponse est
souvent quand on ne connaît pas la
réponse
on procède par élimination procéder par
élimination c'est à dire procéder par
reconnaissance de ce qui est faux c'est
ça la dialectique au sens socratique la
dialectique comme méthode de discussion
menant aux vrais par réfutation du faux
sauf que dans cette vidéo on va parler
de la dialectique chez hegel et que chez
hegel la dialectique ne se résume pas à
cette méthode de raisonnement ou
d'investigation du vrai la dialectique
englobe beaucoup plus de choses la
dialectique hégélienne englobe tous ceux
qui paient elle englobe tout le réel ce
qui veut dire
que pour eagle tout est dialectique
aussi bien la réalité matérielle que la
réalité spirituelle
c'est à dire la pensée les idées
l'esprit et s'il fallait
et définir brièvement la dialectique
chez hegel
on pourrait dire que la dialectique
désigne le processus qui fait que tout
ce qui existe
passe toujours par son contraire
ces salles élément clé de la définition
de la dialectique schengen tout ce qui
existe passe toujours par son contraire
alors comme je sais que ça vous paraîtra
sans doute un peu abstrait ben je veux
pas perdre de temps je vais vous donner
directement un premier exemple
extrêmement concret on va prendre
l'exemple de l'étudiant qui décide de
faire une école de commerce il a son bac
en poche il se dit bon ben maintenant je
vais pouvoir enfin choisir ce que j'ai
envie de faire et dont il choisit
l'école de commerce larmes
le premier semestre se dérouler notre
étudiants commencent à sentir que ça lui
plaît pas tant que ça il s'ennuie il
sent qu'il n'est pas fait pour ça mais
comme on lui a inculqué la
responsabilité il va jusqu'au bout de
son année il a valid et là où ses
parents sont très fiers de lui qu'il ait
validé son année lui se retrouve avec
une forme de gênes une forme de
frustration
certes il a eu son année mais il n'a
éprouvé aucun plaisir à faire ce qu'ils
faisaient n'a aucune satisfaction aucune
gloire et ils se demandent même si il
n'a pas fait une erreur
donc il va passer son été à à réfléchir
et là il va être balloté entre deux
désirs contradictoires premier désir va
être celui d'arrêter ses études pour
faire quelque chose qu'ils aiment la
deuxième option étant de poursuivre de
percer
errer dans cette voie dont il commence à
soupçonner qu'elles ne le rendra pas
heureux ne voulant pas décevoir ses
parents ne voulant pas non plus prendre
de risques inconsidérés pour son avenir
et décide de remettre le couvert pour
une deuxième année
et là rien ne va plus parce que plus le
temps passe et plus notre étudiant se
rend compte qu'il n'est pas fait pour ça
plus notre étudiant se rend compte qu'il
est en train de perdre son temps mais
toujours animé de son sens de la
responsabilité notre étudiants terminent
l'année valide sa deuxième année et ses
parents sont très fiers de lui y est
tout le monde le félicite pour sa
réussite
sauf que notre étudiant n'a pas
l'impression d'avoir réussi
il a toujours l'impression d'avoir perdu
son temps et c'est à ce moment là qu'il
prend sa décision
il décide d'arrêter ses études de
commerce et de se lancer dans sa passion
qui est la musique évidemment ses
parents sont scandalisés
ils ne comprennent pas cette décision
ils s'y opposent
mais rien à faire notre étudiant a
décidé qu'il ne reprendrait pas les
études de commerce
la morale de cette histoire c'est que
notre étudiant a dû en passer par deux
ans de contraintes deux ans de
souffrance pour finalement se rendre
compte que sa vocation se trouvait
ailleurs il aura fallu deux ans pour
qu'il prenne la décision de se
réorienter et de vivre de sa passion
la dialectique c'est le fait que notre
étudiant devait en passer par là pour se
rendre compte
qu'il n'était pas fait pour ça pour se
rendre compte de sa voix n'était pas là
alors bien sûr certains d'entre vous
diront mais il le savait depuis le début
au fond de lui il savait très bien
oui peut-être qu'il le savait au fond de
lui mais encore fallait-il que ce savoir
parviennent jusqu'à sa conscience encore
fallait-il que ce savoir se manifeste et
se manifeste à tel point qu'il ne puisse
plus être niée se manifeste avec
tellement d'évidence qu'à ce moment là
la décision devient fatale la dianétique
c'est le processus par lequel je fais
l'expérience de ce qui n'est pas moins
je fais l'expérience de la contradiction
et tout ce qui est obéit à cette loi
implacable de la dialectique
je vais prendre un deuxième exemple je
vais prendre l'exemple de l'adolescent
qu'est ce qu'un adolescent
c'est un individu en mutation pourquoi
en mutation parce que l'adolescence
c'est une période transitoire entre
l'enfance et l'âge adulte
et qu'est ce qu'on observe bien souvent
chez les adolescents pas toujours mais
fréquemment s'éteint
dire de ne plus être traité comme un
enfant c'est un désir d'être reconnu
comme un individu à part entière un
individu qui possède son identité ses
goûts son libre arbitre
ce n'est évidemment pas un hasard si les
adolescents sont les plus sensibles à la
mode parce que la mode nous procure un
sentiment d'appartenance identitaire
c'est donc une médiation vers la
construction de l'identité individuelle
et remarqué comme l'adolescent est temps
en opposition avec les schémas
traditionnels et notamment avec le
schéma autoritaire de ses parents
l'adolescent se construit par opposition
à l'autorité parentale
cela pourra passer par des choses
extrêmement concrètes se teindre les
cheveux en vert s'habiller comme l'as de
pique
enfin tout ce que les adolescents
s'affairent pour se distinguer et le
parent qui se trouvent confrontés à la
crise d'adolescence et le mot crise est
intéressant puisqu'il fait référence à
l'idée de mutation justement parents qui
est confronté à sarm bas il a deux
options la première option c'est de
vouloir empêcher
cette crise de vouloir l'endiguer donc
il va par exemple ordonné à son enfant
de se faire décolorer les cheveux de
s'habiller de manière un petit peu plus
classique et de bien vouloir cesser de
faire l'intéressant ça c'est la première
réaction
la deuxième réaction ça consiste à se
dire que ce qui définit l'adolescence
c'est précisément l'opposition c'est
l'opposition comme moyen d'affirmation
de soi et de constructions individuelles
partant de là que l'adolescent se
comportent en adolescent ne doit pas
être considérée comme un problème à
résoudre
il faut que l'adolescent en passe par là
pour se construire et pour devenir
l'adulte qu'il est appelé à devenir on
peut pas s'opposer à une étape qui est
fatal
on ne peut pas s'opposer à quelque chose
qui de toute façon doit arriver parce
que s'il ne passe pas par cette étape
l'adolescent ne deviendra jamais un
adulte il a besoin d'en passer par cette
expérience de la contradiction pour
devenir ce qu'il est il a besoin de se
confronter à cette altérité qu'il réfute
pour pouvoir ensuite se réconcilier avec
elle c'est généralement ce qui fait
qu'on s'entend beaucoup mieux avec nos
parents quand on devient adulte c'est à
dire quand on quitte le foyer d'oxydé
c'est que l'adolescence en tant que
période marquée par la recherche de
l'opposition est absolument
indispensable empêcher qu'une étape
inéluctable se produise c'est créer
davantage de problèmes qu'on n'en résout
et ce genre de schéma d'opposition vous
pouvez l'appliquer à absolument tout
tout ce qui s'inscrit dans un processus
évolutif
ça marche par exemple avec les relations
de couple
qu'est ce qui se passe dans une relation
de couple habituel les deux personnes se
rencontrent elles se plaisent elle
décide d'aller plus loin dans leurs
relations
éventuellement de vivre ensemble et puis
au bout d'un certain temps vont
commencer à apparaître les premiers
désagréments
on va commencer à remarquer les défauts
de l'autre
pour finir par ne plus voir que ça va
finir par être agacé par les défauts de
l'autre
et puis voir arriver les premières
disputes les premiers conflits parfois
ces conflits se régleront mais parfois
ces conflits seront destructeur pour
faire que les deux personnes vont se
séparer et peut-être ne plus vouloir
entendre parler l'une de l'autre
donc on va bloquer l'ex sur facebook on
va effacer son numéro on va éviter de
fréquenter les endroits qu'il ou elle
fréquente
parce qu'au fond on a toujours une sorte
de rancoeur ça ça correspond à l'étape
de la réfutation à l'étape de la
contradiction on veut nier la personne
avec qui on a passé une partie de notre
vie mais c'est une volonté totalement
vaine
parce que cette personne qu'on cherche à
éliminer symboliquement de notre vie
elle continue à exister non seulement à
l'extérieur de nom elle vit toujours
mais aussi à l'intérieur de nous la
personne aura laissé en nous la trace de
son passage que ce soit pas à re les
photos les souvenirs mais aussi par
l'influent ce que cette personne aura eu
pour nous puisque qu'on le veuille ou
non les relations qu'on entretient avec
les autres nos influences et modifient
notre personnalité
quand tu es quelqu'un c'est lui donner
la possibilité de les influencer
donc la personne
chaniers que l'on cherche à exclure
sortir de notre vie mais on voit que
c'est peine perdue parce que elle y
restera
et c'est là qu'on en arrive à la
troisième étape du processus dialectique
qui consiste dans la réconciliation
c'est le fait de se dire que cette
personne dont on ne veut plus entendre
parler
elle nous a malgré tout apporter des
choses ella a contribué en partie à
faire de nous ce que nous sommes donc
vouloir nier cette personne
ce serait comme vouloir nier une partie
de soi
or vouloir nier une partie de soi c'est
destructeur et l'être humain ne peut pas
vivre indéfiniment dans
l'autodestruction la réconciliation ou
le pardon va être le moyen de dépasser
la contradiction pardonner c'est
considérer que tout ce qui a eu lieu
devait avoir lieu et qu'on comprend que
ça ait dû avoir lieu
on comprend que le conflit était
finalement inévitable mais que ce n'est
pas parce que le conflit était
inévitable que tout s'arrête à ce
conflit ce n'est pas parce que le
conflit devait arriver on ne peut pas
dépasser le conflit et en se
réconciliant même virtuellement avec la
personne avec laquelle on est en conflit
on passe le troisième stade de la
vieille éthique
le stade de la réconciliation stade de
l'unification égale utilise un mot en
allemand pour désigner ce processus
c'est ce qu'ils appellent à auffay bon
et à offenburg
c'est un mot qui veut dire trois choses
à la fois à auffay book signifie tout à
la fois supprimé conserver est dépassé
et c
le coeur de la dialectique une
suppression conservation dépassement
pourquoi suppression parce que
suis en conflit avec quelqu'un ou
quelque chose peut-être avec moi même je
suis dans un désir de suppression je
suis dans un désir de réfutation de
l'autre mais en même temps que je le
réfute
je conserve en moins ce qu'il m'a
apporté
je conserve en moi la trace de son
passage
on vient de le voir avec l'exemple du
couple qui se sépare
je ne peux pas annulé l'expérience que
j'ai eue avec l'autre je ne peux pas
appuyer sur la touche reset sans que la
relation ne soient conservées dans
l'historique donc il ya conservation il
y as dépassement lorsque je surmonte la
contradiction
lorsque la contradiction ne devient plus
l'alpha et l'oméga de la relation mais
simplement une étape de la relation
une étape qu'il m'est possible de
dépasser la dialectique désigne ainsi ce
schéma auquel rien n'échappe d'un triple
mouvement qu'on al'habitude de résumer
avec le schéma thèse antithèse synthèse
l'essentiel qui est en jeu dans la
notion dialectique
c'est cette idée de mouvement perpétuel
et cette idée de mouvement qui passe par
l'opposition qui passe par la
contradiction et qui fait que la
contradiction jouer un rôle absolument
moteur est déterminant dans toute
évolution
alors ici il faut absolument que je
fasse une précision très importante
parce que si je ne la fais pas
maintenant je risquerais de vous donner
mauvaise idée de ce qu'est la
dialectique chez aig depuis tout à
l'heure je parle de la directive comme
d'un processus qui anime le réel anime
tout ce qui est et ce qu'il faut
bien retenir c'est que la dialectique
concerne également la vie intérieure la
dialectique fonctionne également pour ce
qui relève de la pensée de la conscience
de l'esprit c'est à dire que nos idées
elles mêmes sont soumises à ce schéma
dialectique et à cette évolution qui
passe elle aussi par la contradiction
nos pensées n'échappe pas au processus
dialectique et pour l'illustrer je vais
prendre un exemple
jamas et qui l'exemple du trajet en
voiture
imaginez que vous êtes invités à une
soirée entre amis vous fait le trajet en
voiture et vous y allez accompagner vous
avez quelqu'un à la place du passager et
ce passage m
vous dites qu'il connaît un chemin plus
rapide que celui que vous vous apprêtez
à prendre
je connais un chemin qui permet de
gagner du temps là vous avez deux
options soit vous lui répondez non merci
ça ira je connais le trajet j'ai
l'habitude
sinon vous avez l'option d'essayer de
faire l'expérience de cette altérité qui
vous ai suggéré pour éventuellement
comparaît pour éventuellement vérifier
si vous aviez raison ou tort supposons
que vous fassiez le
choix de suivre votre propre trajet il
est fort possible que vous ayez eu
raison il est fort possible que votre
trajet et était le plus court mais le
problème c'est que n'ayant pas fait
l'expérience de l'autre trajet ayant pas
fait l'expérience de la contradiction
bien vous ne pouvez pas en être
absolument sûr vous vivez à ce moment là
dans la certitude de votre savoir
vous vivez à ce moment là dans la
croyance mais cette croyance vous ne
l'avez pas exposé au feu de la
contradiction ne l'avait pas mise à
l'épreuve de la réfutation
ce qui veut dire que même si vous avez
raison dans les faits même si votre
trajet est effectivement plus court
vous n'aurez pas saisi l'opportunité qui
vous était offerte de le vérifier et
donc votre savoir n'en est pas vraiment
un
maintenant imaginons la deuxième option
vous choisissez de suivre la suggestion
de votre ami et d'emprunter son trajet
et là vous vous rendez compte qu'en fait
ben au lieu de gagner du temps vous en
avez perdu est ce que ça veut dire pour
autant que vous aurez perdu votre temps
et bien non vous n'aurez pas perdu votre
temps on n'aurait pas perdu 5 minutes
vous aurez investi cinq minutes dans la
vérification d'une idée vous aurait
investi cinq minutes dans l'expérience
de la contradiction qui vous aura permis
d'améliorer votre savoir qui vous aura
permis de solidifier ce que vous saviez
le savoir que vous possédez à l'issue de
votre trajet n'est donc pas votre savoir
initial c'est votre savoir initial
augmenté d'une nouvelle connaissance
donc les plus votre savoir initial
c'est un savoir plus abouti c'est un
savoir plus complet et c'est ça l'idée
de la dialectique à savoir qu'une
expérience qui à première vue ne vous
apprends rien ou à première vue ne fait
que confirmer ce que vous saviez déjà
en réalité modifie ce que vous saviez la
confirmation d'un savoir modifie la
nature de ce savoir et c'est la raison
pour laquelle vouloir absolument
protéger ses croyances vouloir les
mettre à l'abri de la réfutation
c'est la pire chose que l'on puisse
faire c'est la pire chose que l'on
puisse faire parce qu'à ce moment là on
ne met plus notre savoir en position de
s'améliorer le concept de dialectique
est indissociable de l'idée d'évolution
tout ce qui existe évolué rien n'est
jamais identique à soi et c'est quand
on comprend que l'évolution n'est pas
simplement un paramètre de l'existence
mais le moteur même de tout ce qui
existe c'est quand on comprend cette
idée qu'on comprend que tout des
dialectiques imaginer qu'on apprenne un
enfant les mathématiques
alors on commence par lui apprendre à
compter donc on commença à 0 et ensuite
un deux trois quatre cinq etc
on va lui apprendre les nombres entiers
plus précisément les nombres entiers
naturels
c'est à dire positif mais lorsqu'on
apprend ça un enfant on ne lui dit pas
qu'il est en train d'apprendre les
nombres entiers naturels
on lui dit qu'il est en train
d'apprendre les nombres tout court donc
d'un point de vue totalement objectif on
lui ment à cet enfant puisque on lui
fait croire que les nombres se résume se
réduisent aux nombres entiers naturels
pourquoi est ce qu on fait ça on fait ça
parce qu'on est conscient qu'on peut pas
lui demander de retenir à son âge
des notions aussi complexe que nombres
entiers naturels ou nombre relatif et on
trouverait pédagogiquement absurde de
lui apprendre les nombres négatifs
à ce stade de son apprentissage il doit
donc en passer par une première étape
les nombres entiers naturels pour
ensuite découvrir qu'il y a d'autres
ensemble de nombres et c'est seulement
lorsqu'il aura acquis lorsqu'il aura
enregistré cette première étape qui
pourra passer à l'étape suivante et se
rendre compte que ce qu'il avait cru
être la totalité du vrai quand il se
sera aperçu que ce qu'il croyait être
vrai n'était que partiellement vrai à ce
moment là il pourra passer l'étape
suivante de l'apprentissage et dont il
va apprendre par exemple les nombres
négatifs il avait
besoin d'en passer par l'erreur c'est à
dire la partialité une erreur n'est
jamais totalement une erreur du point de
vue hégélien une erreur c'est une
connaissance partielle
c'est une connaissance incomplète donc
l'erreur n'est pas à disqualifier en
tant que tel
l'erreur est à assumer et à reconnaître
parce qu'elle est la condition du
progrès de la connaissance la
dialectique nous dit qu'on n'entre pas
dans la vérité
d'emblée par un saut on parvient à la
vérité au terme d'un processus qui passe
par une série de contradictions de ce
que l'on croyait être vrai donc pour
eagle
il est nécessaire de se tromper il est
nécessaire de passer par l'erreur car
l'erreur n'est pas le contraire de la
vérité
l'erreur est une marche sur le chemin de
la vérité
alors à ce moment là on pourrait se
poser la question mais pourquoi en
passer par l'erreur est ce qu'il ne
serait pas plus simple d'arriver
directement à la bonne réponse
est-ce qu'on avait vraiment besoin de
nier l'existence des nombres négatifs
pour pouvoir ensuite les apprendre et
les comprendre est-ce que j'ai besoin de
me tromper de route pour me rendre
compte que finalement la route ce que je
pensais être la bonne était
effectivement la bonne est-ce que j'ai
vraiment besoin d'en passer par l'erreur
est ce qu'il n'est pas plus simple de
recevoir la vérité par quelqu'un qui la
possèdent et de l'appliquer de
l'accepter comme étant la vérité est ce
que ce serait pas au fond beaucoup plus
facile pour nous
évidemment je pense que en même temps
que je formule ma question vous en
déduisez vous même la réponse c'est que
si je fais ça là ça suppose beaucoup
trop de choses qui me font abandonner
mon pouvoir de vérification
mon pouvoir d'apprentissage personnel et
sa eagle le réfute
pour eagle ne vont pas recevoir la
connaissance d'une autorité extérieure
donc ce qui veut dire une chose très
importante d'un point de vue et des
liens c'est que la connaissance est
toujours le fruit d'une expérience
individuelle à l'échelle de l'individu
la connaissance elle procède d'une
expérience personnelle
alors qu'est ce qu'on appelle une
expérience personnelle ya pour eagle
l'expérience c'est tout ce qu'on vit à
voir de la pratique dans un domaine
faire des rencontres lire des livres
tout ça ça fait partie de l'expérience
personnelle nos réflexions nos
introspection nos méditation tout ça
aussi ça fait partie de l'expérience
personnelle tout ce qu'on vit fait
partie de l'expérience personnelle et
tout ce qu'on vit participe du processus
de la connaissance
lorsque vous
rencontrez quelqu'un vous allez
apprendre à faire connaissance avec
cette personne et puis au bout d'un
certain temps vous allez peut-être
franchir une étape dans la relation
par exemple vous allez découvrir les
défauts de la personne étant entendu que
j'appelle ici défaut ce qui constitue un
défaut à vos yeux
à ce moment-là peut-être allez-vous
faire l'expérience de la déception
la déception parce que vous vous étiez
peut-être construit une image de la
personne
et lorsque vous vous rendez compte que
cette personne ne coïncident pas
exactement avec l'image que vous vous en
étiez fait vous allez être déçus mais
finalement cette déception ce n'est une
déception que de votre point de vue
c'est vous qui aviez mis sur sept
personnes des attentes qu'elle était
pour ainsi dire pas en mesure de
satisfaire
vous allez faire l'expérience de la
déception
et cette expérience en soi va
représenter un apprentissage
elle va représenter une évolution de ce
que vous êtes et de ce que vous savez
car pour peu que vous soyez attentifs à
ce sentiment de la déception
vous allez vous dire qu'après tout cette
personne a bien le droit d'être ce
qu'elle est vous vous n'avez peut-être
pas le droit d'exiger que cette personne
soit ce que vous avez voulu qu'elle soit
cette expérience a priori négative
négative
de votre point de vue elle n'est donc
pas que négative
elle n'est pas que négative parce
qu'alors
apporter quelque chose de positif elle
vous aura apporté la conscience et la
compréhension qu'une personne est ce
qu'elle est indépendamment de votre
vouloir et ça pour eagle c'est décisif
c'est ce qui fait toute la différence
car une expérience négative a toujours
un revers positif et le revers positif
de l'expérience négative
c'est ce que l'expérience négative nous
apprend l'expérience négative nous
apprend quelque chose et c'est en cela
qu'elle est positive
in fine et elle n'est pas positive quand
vous allez là vivre elle devient
positive quand vous l'aurez comprise
et quand vous aurez compris qu'elle
était nécessaire pour que vous
compreniez ce que nous dit hegel c'est
que la compréhension ne se fait
de manière immédiate elle se fait
toujours de manière indirecte par étapes
et les étapes qui mènent à la
compréhension sont toujours des étapes
douloureuses parce qu'elles contredisent
ce que l'on pensait savoir ce que l'on
croyait ou ce que l'on désirait c'est ça
la dialectique et c'est ça la vertu de
la dialectique la vertu de la
dialectique c'est qu'elle nous permet de
comprendre qu'une expérience négative
n'est jamais totalement négative qu'elle
a toujours un versant positif et qu'il
dépend de nous de reconnaître ce ver
sont positifs même si en réalité et
qu'elle nous explique que ce n'est pas
vraiment nous qui choisissons d'en avoir
conscience
c'est plutôt cette conscience elle même
qui s'imposent à nous mais peu importe
ce qui compte c'est de comprendre que la
dialectique est un processus qui régit
tout et quand je dis qui régit tous je
veux dire qui régit à la fois les
phénomènes matériel mais aussi les
phénomènes mentaux les pensées ont
construit notre connaissance par
négation de notre connaissance
antérieure par négation par réfutation
de ce que l'on croyait être vrai car le
propre de la croyance c'est qu'elle se
présente toujours à nous sous la forme
d'une connaissance personne ne pense que
sa croyance est irrationnel ou absurdes
tout le monde a de bonnes raisons de
croire ce qu'ils croient donc la
connaissance est toujours une
connaissance du point de vue de
l'individu qui en fait l'expérience et
c'est seulement lorsque cette
connaissance se voit contredite par une
expérience par une série d'expériences
que l'individu grâce à sa conscience va
pouvoir faire un retour sur sa
connaissance antérieure pour se dire que
finalement cette connaissance elle
n'était pas complètement valable
elle n'était pas anti
armand fausse mais elle raté quelque
chose et ça ça demande énormément
d'humilité d'accepter que l'on se soit
trompé ou d'accepter que l'on n'avait
pas tout vu tout pris en compte et que
certains pas
m nous échapper et qu'il a fallu qu'il
nous échappe pour que l'on se rende
compte qu'on est maîtrisée pas tous la
dialectique
c'est donc un processus qui concerne à
la fois les phénomènes matériel et les
phénomènes immatériel pour l'heure
retenons simplement cette idée à la fois
simple on met très subtiles qui est que
tous ceux qui déploie son existence dans
le temps passe par des étapes qui se
contredisent les unes les autres et qui
pourtant forme une totalité cohérente
quand on comprend ce principe de la
dialectique on devient beaucoup plus
indulgent envers l'erreur car alors on a
conscience que l'erreur est toujours la
condition de la vérité que l'erreur est
nécessaire pour pouvoir la dépasser à
condition de faire preuve de
suffisamment d'humilité pour reconnaître
une erreur quand on l'a commise celui
qui refuse d'expérimenter ce processus
dialectique refuse en même temps de
reconnaître ce processus dialectique à
l'oeuvre dans tout ce qui existe celui
qui n'évolue pas fait la preuve qu'il
n'apprend rien celui qui refuse
d'expérimenter l'évolution refuse de
comprendre que tout évolue
or qu'est-ce qu'il ya
fonction de reconnaître ce processus
c'est précisément la conscience la
conscience c'est ce dont nous sommes
dotés qui nous permet à la fois de
savoir que le monde existe mais aussi de
comprendre comment le monde évolue
comment les événements se produisent le
rôle de la conscience c'est de
reconnaître et d'identifier seul à être
conscients au sens hégélien ça veut donc
dire être attentif au processus parfois
contradictoires parfois paradoxaux qui
conduisent à un événement et la
compréhension est un événement
comprendre comment le monde évolue c'est
se donner l'occasion de comprendre
comment la conscience elle même évolué
c'est comprendre comment nos pensées se
construisent dans le temps comment nos
opinions évoluent au profit de tel ou
tel autre et c'est comprendre que
derrière chacune de nos erreurs
il y à un pas de plus vers la vérité un
pas de plus vers ce que hegel appelle le
royaume de l'esprit
donc que faire
conscience la conscience elle
expérimente le monde et en expérimentant
le monde elle s'expérimente elle même
elle expérimente la manière dont elle
réagit au monde
elle expérimente le fait qu'elle se
crispait devant une pensée autres une
pensée qui s'oppose elle expérimente le
fait qu'elle est capable aussi parfois
d'accepter la contradiction comme un
élément d'évolution comme un élément qui
va la faire progresser
elle fait l'expérience de sa propre
humilité quand elle accepte de se
laisser modifié par une nouvelle
information ou elle fait l'expérience de
sa résistance du fait qu'elle ne veut
pas évolué et qu'elle veut rester seul
avec elle même
on fait beaucoup dépendre notre estime
de soi même de nos idées nos valeurs de
nos opinions et si on s'aperçoit que
l'une de nos croyances on peut être
réfuté ou va rarement accueillir ça avec
le sourire
on va plutôt avoir tendance à défendre
notre opinion jusqu'au bout un peu comme
un kamikaze qui voudrait à tout prix tué
son ennemi avant de mourir lui-même ça
c'est la réaction de lego c'est l'ego
qui s'identifient à cette pensée qui
veut survivre et il a parfaitement
raison en tant qu ego de vouloir
survivre
sauf
que plus légaux va chercher à survivre
et plus la vérité au sens hégélien c'est
à dire le processus par lequel on
améliore notre connaissance plus la
vérité est en péril lego et la vérité ne
se bat pas pour la même chose d'ailleurs
on pourrait dire que la vérité en elle
même ne se bat jamais la vérité se donne
mais les gosses bas et un égo contredit
n'ai pas un ego qui se remet en cause un
ego entre 10 est un ego qui se défend
qui s'engagent dans ce qu'elle appelle
une lutte à mort la lutte à mort
c'est la seule stratégie que l'ego peut
adopter en cas de réfutation
c'est la stratégie de la survie ce que
nous dit hegel c'est que la conscience
doit mourir à chaque nouvelle
contradiction pour renaître enrichi par
cette contradiction
l'évolution est le moteur de l'existence
et évoluer c'est se donner la
possibilité de se réorienter évoluer ce
n'est pas nier ce que l'on ait évolué
c'est se donner la possibilité de
devenir ce que l'on est
pour eagle il n'y a pas d'échec au sens
où il n'y a pas à regretter d'avoir été
dans l'erreur
il n'y a pas à regretter d'avoir été
dans l'erreur puisque l'erreur est un
morceau de la vérité est que ce morceau
de la vérité ne pourra grossir que si
l'on accepte qu'il n'était que partielle
ce n'est qu'à l'échelle de l'absolu une
vérité peut devenir une vérité mais pour
ce qui est de notre expérience d'êtres
humains ne sommes jamais dans la vérité
nous sommes toujours dans la vérité
partielle nous sommes toujours dans le
demi vrai le demi-fond et cette partie
manquante de la vérité ne s'obtient que
lorsque l'on reconnaît qu'elle nous fait
défaut
le sous titre de la phénoménologie de
l'esprit de hegel ces sciences de
l'expérience de la conscience et la
dialectique permet de comprendre le
principe de cette expérience de la
conscience une expérience qui nous fait
passer d'une contradiction à une autre
le monde étant plurielle le monde et en
hiver tout ce qui n'est pas nous
s'opposent à nous tous qui n'est pas
nous nous contredit et je vous mets au
défi de trouver ne serait-ce qu'une
seule personne qui partage absolument
intégralement toutes vos pensées toutes
vos croyances tous vos désirs
je ne prend pas beaucoup de risques en
vous lançant ce défi parce que ça
n'existe pas du simple fait qu'il n'y a
pas deux individus strictement identique
le monde est marqué par la diversité
donc le monde est marqué par l'altérité
ce qui veut dire que potentiellement
toute nouvelle expérience peut être
l'expérience de la contradiction est une
contradiction au sens et des liens n'a
rien de négatif
au contraire la conte
sion est vécue subjectivement de manière
négative avant d'être comprise comme
s'insérant dans un processus global
d'évolution et donc d'être perçue sous
son versant positif toute nouvelle
expérience nous met potentiellement face
à la contradiction c'est à dire face à
l'opportunité de nous améliorer
si vous vous retrouver confronté à une
altérité avec laquelle vous ne vous
opposez pas ça peut arriver dans ce cas
là est ce que ça veut dire que la
dialectique hégélienne et mises en échec
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya des cas
où peut-être elle ne s'applique pas non
ça signifie quelque chose de beaucoup
plus simple qui est que cette altérité
n'était peut-être pas réellement une
altérité
ce n'était peut-être qu une altérité
dont vous aviez déjà fait l'expérience
et dans ce cas là cette altérité n'en
est plus vraiment une
cette altérité vous l'avez incorporé à
vous vous lavez assimilés et donc vous
n'avez pas le sentiment d'avoir affaire
à une opposition
vous avez le sentiment d'avoir affaire à
quelque chose que vous avez déjà
rencontré que vous avez déjà accepté les
différentes
science qui sont en interaction au
quotidien ne sont peut-être pas
adversaires ne sont peut-être pas fait
pour s'opposer et et lutter jusqu'à la
mort tête les différentes conscience
sont simplement là pour reconnaître dans
les autres une partie de la totalité
ainsi augmenter leur champ de conscience
la dialectique mène chez hegel à
l'augmentation de notre champ de
conscience et pour augmenter ce champ de
conscience
il est nécessaire d'en passer par
l'opposition je prenais l'exemple tout à
l'heure du trajet en voiture vous avez
besoin de faire vous même l'expérience
du trajet en voiture pour savoir si
votre trajet est effectivement plus
court ou pas que celui qu'on vous
propose vous avez parfois besoin de vous
opposer à une autorité pour pouvoir vous
construire sur le plan identitaire avoir
l'esprit de contradiction
pour un adolescent c'est presque une
tautologie
c'est presque le principe même de ce
qu'il se produit à l'adolescence
l'adolescent est obligé de vivre son
adolescence et c'est seulement parce
qu'il aura vécu son adolescence qu'il
pourra dépasser le stade de
l'adolescence qui pourra regarder les
photos qui datent de son adolescence en
se disant enfin c'était ridicule je me
rendais pas compte
j'ai honte alors on n'est pas obligé
d'avoir honte
on peut simplement sourire d'un sourire
bienveillant envers le jeune être que
l'on a été en se disant bon il fallait
que j'en passe par cette étape c'est pas
grave ça fait partie de l'ordre naturel
des choses et donc à 25 ans quand il se
dira de manière un peu condescendante
qu'il était bien idiot qu'il n'avait
aucun goût qui le suivait la mode comme
un mouton à ce moment là ce jeune homme
de 25 ans aura l'impression que là ça y
est là ça y est il est dans la vérité
il est dans la connaissance il est dans
la compréhension il pense qu'il a
définitivement raison et qu'est ce qu'il
va se passer dix ans plus tard eh bien
il va regarder les photos de l'époque où
il avait 25 ans et il repensera à ses
choix à son mode de vie à ce qu'il a pu
faire entreprendre échoué lorsqu'il
avait 25 ans et la 1re belote
il va se dire qu'est ce que j'étais naïf
qu'est-ce que j'étais prétentieux
qu'est-ce que j'étais arrogant et c'est
ainsi que va se construire l'évolution
de cet individu à travers le temps par
reconnaissance successives de ce qu'il a
été et paris
sion de ce qu'il a été aussi comme
conditions d'évolution eagle nous dit
bien qu'on ne peut réellement évolué que
si l'on est persuadé à chaque instant
d'être dans la vérité
on a besoin de se croire dans la vérité
pour que la contradiction soit efficace
vivre les différentes étapes de notre
vie c'est se mettre en risque c'est se
mettre en danger
c'est accepter les preuves de la
contradiction comme une épreuve
bienfaitrice ans c'est comprendre comme
le disait nietzsche que ce qui ne nous
tue pas nous rend plus forts et que ce
qui nous fait mal
nous élèves la dialectique
c'est l'idée que rien ne remplace
l'expérience et que l'expérience par
définition est faite de tout et son
contraire et que c'est par le contraire
qu'on accède au tout
c'est par la contradiction qu'on dépasse
en permanence l'état où nous sommes
c'est seulement par l'expérience du
monde et la conscience de notre
expérience du monde
la conscience d'être conscients de notre
c'est seulement à ce prix que l'on peut
s'accomplir devenir complet devenir ce
que nous sommes
devenir ce que nous sommes voués à être
je vous remercie
[Musique]
et